[Music]  hey it's conan o'brien again and it's  time to answer the fourth question this  question comes from danielle nusiforo  from monterey california the question is  hi conan where's your pal andy  that's a great question a lot of people  been asking what about andy i'm very  sorry to tell you andy richter will not  be part of the new show on tbs uh  he kind of went off the grid after the  last show we have not spoken i haven't  seen andy i don't really know what he's  doing what his plans are but he will not  be part of the new show what are you  doing  doing a  web thing oh  i was cake in the kitchen  cool  he's around he'll be on the show  every night you'll see them soon  if you've got other questions  contact me at facebook.com teamcoco and  i'll try and answer them  more truthfully next time  [Music]  where were you going there's no even  room over there i was just off camera oh  what do you think i'm gonna leave no i  don't i didn't see you leave you just